Chris Pratt went from that funny chubby guy
on Parks and Recreation to bonafide movie
star almost overnight thanks to his starring
roles in blockbusters like Guardians of the
Galaxy and and Jurassic World.
But for much of his early career, it seemed
as if he was destined to play on the sidelines,
as boyfriends in romantic comedies or co-workers
with only a handful of lines.
Here are some under-the-radar roles Pratt
played before he became a global superstar.
Everwood
Pratt's first big break came in 2002 when
he was cast as Bright Abbott, a jock with
a heart of gold, on the critically acclaimed
WB series Everwood.
Pratt stayed with the show throughout its
four-season run, most of which dealt with
Bright's on-again, off-again relationship
with Hannah.
In real life, though, Pratt wound up dating
his on-screen sister, Revenge's Emily Van
Camp, for a number of years.
They split in 2007.
Strangers With Candy
In 2005, Pratt landed a part in the big-screen
version of Amy Sedaris' cult TV comedy, Strangers
with Candy.
In it, he played Brason, another high school
jock who becomes the object of Jerri Blank's
lusty, wacked-out desires.
As far as the Chris Pratt Film Canon goes,
Strangers with Candy will likely be remembered
best as That Time Chris Rocked a Hilarious,
If Unfortunate, Mullet.
The O.C.
By the time The O.C. headed into its fourth
and final season, most people had abandoned
the once top-rated teen soap due to its recycled
plotlines and stale acting.
Those who stuck around, however, were treated
to an unexpected creative revival, due in
great part to Pratt's performance as Summer's
free-spirited dorm-mate, Che.
Pratt infused the show with laughs, heart,
and welcomed weirdness, allowing The O.C.
to end on a higher note than anyone could
have hoped.
Wanted
Although Pratt is now known for playing hunky,
charming leading men, there was a time in
his career when he was relegated to roles
like "That Coworker You Just Want to Punch
in the Face."
Such was the case in the 2008 Angelina Jolie
action flick Wanted, in which Pratt angered
co-star James McAvoy's character so much,
he eventually got smacked in the face with
a keyboard.
"Yeah, that was great, bro.
Who's the man?"
Bride Wars
Another pre-fame role Pratt had to try on
for size: playing the bro-y, suit-and-tie-wearing
fiance, as seen in the disastrous 2009 rom-com
Bride Wars.
Fortunately for Pratt fans, his role in the
embarrassing flop was overshadowed by the
insane antics of Kate Hudson and Pratt's on-screen
love interest, Anne Hathaway.
Moneyball
Pratt got his first legitimate taste of prestige,
award-winning movies when Sony cast him to
play real-life first baseman, Scott Hatteberg,
in the 2011 baseball drama Moneyball.
"What's your biggest fear?"
"A baseball being hit in my general direction."
Although the role was small, Pratt held his
own opposite his mega-famous co-star, Brad
Pitt, and even dropped 30 pounds to secure
the role.
Moneyball marked a stark contrast to Pratt's
goofy, affable Andy on Parks and Recreation,
setting him up for big movie roles for years
to come.
Zero Dark Thirty
One year after Moneyball hit theaters, Pratt
once again found himself at the center of
an awards-magnet movie — this time, in Kathryn
Bigelow's Zero Dark Thirty, about the U.S.
hunt for Osama bin Laden.
Pratt played one of the Navy SEALs who helped
take bin Laden down.
"So UBL?
You got an intel source on the ground?"
"No."
"No?
Okay, so how do you know it's Bin Laden?"
Her
In 2013, Pratt appeared in his third-consecutive
Best Picture nominee, Her, from writer-director
Spike Jonze.
This time around, he played a coworker who
goes out on a double-date with Joaquin
Phoenix and his virtual, body-less girlfriend
Samantha, voiced by Scarlett Johansson — which
is just as weird as it sounds.
"I didn't mean it like that.
I just meant that it was a different experience."
"No, no, no, Samantha, we know exactly what
you mean.
We're all dumb humans."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!